[Music]
three chinese astronauts are orbiting
earth this weekend after their
successful liftoff from the edge of the
gobi desert thursday
they're expected to spend the next few
months helping to create china's version
of the international space station which
is due to be ready as soon as next year
they even switched on the station's
wi-fi service on friday
may then be the only alternative to the
two-decade-old us-backed international
space station which
may be retired in 2024
space they really are serious in wanting
to emerge as a very senior science power
for the benefit of all mankind
this tension in space has roots in
washington congress barred china from
the international space station a decade
ago citing national security
but china pressed ahead it landed a
rover on mars back in the spring
becoming just the second country to do
so
after the u.s i wonder how fast wi-fi is
i don't know can they stream us
playstation are they watching us i hope
they are it would be nice
might be faster than ours
are you judging the i.t people no
just her wi-fi speed that's all she just
needs a new phone